.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Katar -
Austragungsort der Fussball-WM.
Auch Schweizerinnen und Schweizer
tragen im reichen Wüstenstaat
zum reibungslosen Ablauf
des umstrittenen Turniers bei.
Einige von ihnen
leben schon lange hier.
Rund eine Flugstunde entfernt: Dubai,
offener und schillernder als Katar.
Ein Paradies für Fremde -
wenn man sich an die Regeln hält.
Wir begleiten
fünf Schweizerinnen und Schweizer,
die sich auf das Abenteuer
am Golf eingelassen haben.
Worin liegt der Reiz? Was sind
die Herausforderungen des Alltags?
Fühlen sie sich trotz
des Kulturunterschieds heimisch?
In Katars Hauptstadt Doha dreht sich
alles um die Weltmeisterschaft.
Coralie Durussel ist nach ihrem
Mutterschaftsurlaub zurück im Job.
Sie arbeitet für
das Supreme Committee,
die Stelle, die für die FIFA
vor Ort die WM organisiert.
Vor der Eröffnung
türmt sich die Arbeit ...
Das hier ist mein Büro.
Ich bin im Moment allein, weil ich
wegen der Kinder sehr früh aufstehe.
Ausserdem bin ich jemand, der sehr
gerne morgens die Dinge erledigt.
Dass Coralie ihr Büro zeigt,
ist eine absolute Ausnahme.
In ihrem Job hat sie täglich mit den
Botschaften aus aller Welt zu tun.
Eine anspruchsvolle Aufgabe -
und streng vertraulich.
Ja, das ist super interessant
und sehr schwierig,
weil die Botschaften
doch einen gewissen Anspruch
an Etikette und Protokoll haben.
Es ist nicht immer einfach,
aber sehr interessant.
* Sie spricht arabisch. *
Yeah, that's the only thing.
There is a problem.
But no - I mean ...
Nur noch ein halbes Jahr bis zur WM:
Coralie hat alle Hände voll zu tun.
Der tägliche Spagat
zwischen ihrem Job
und den Kindern zu Hause
macht die Sache nicht einfacher.
Unsere Nanny schreibt mir gerade,
dass wir keine Windeln mehr
für meine Tochter haben.
Also kaufe ich jetzt Windeln.
Die Freuden und Leiden
einer arbeitstätigen Mutter,
Multitasking eben ...
Der Wiedereinstieg zwei Monate
nach der Geburt ihrer kleinen Tochter
fällt ihr schwer.
Ich vermisse die Kinder.
Mein Sohn
ist im Kindergarten, das geht.
Aber meine Tochter
ist zu Hause bei der Nanny.
Das will ich natürlich nicht.
Ich wäre lieber zu Hause,
aber im Moment
habe ich leider keine Wahl.
Aber ich hoffe natürlich,
dass sich am 19. Dezember 2022
alles entspannen wird.
Dann werde ich viel mehr
von meinen Kindern haben.
Aber nein, ich habe grossen Respekt
vor berufstätigen Müttern.
Das ist einfach verrückt!
Ich weiss nicht, wie die das machen.
Es ist wirklich, wirklich nicht
einfach. Aber da muss man durch.
Superwomen, as they say. Supermoms.
In Dubai ist Matteo Boffa mit seinen
diversen Start-ups beschäftigt.
Die Stadt
ist ein Eldorado für neue Ideen.
Der gebürtige Tessiner
setzt auf Nachhaltigkeit.
In einem Industriegebiet
ausserhalb der City
lässt er aus alten Werbebannern
neue Umhängetaschen produzieren.
Hey, Mohammad. How are you?
- How are you?
Very good. Very good.
Mohammad Vasim Farooquis
kleine Fabrik besteht seit 2005.
Die Arbeiter stammen aus Indien und
arbeiten, wie sie es gewohnt sind,
z.T. barfuss auf dem Boden.
Auch für Matteo
ein gewöhnungsbedürftiges Bild.
Eine solche Fabrik findet man
in der Schweiz wohl nicht.
Es ist schon schräg,
dieser Gap zwischen Wolkenkratzer,
Glamour und Gold
und nur wenige Minuten entfernt
ein Umfeld wie dieses hier.
Statt im Müll landen alte Werbebanner
aus Plastik unter der Nähmaschine
und werden zu Geld:
Upcycling nennt sich das.
Ich liebe diese Art Arbeit.
Als Matteo mir davon erzählte,
war ich überrascht, dass wir
so etwas auch bei uns machen können.
Wir schaffen aus alten Produkten
etwas Neues,
etwas Trendiges
für die nächste Generation.
Mir ist es wichtig, ein Unternehmen
aufzubauen, das nicht nur sozial
oder ökologisch nachhaltig ist,
sondern auch Geld einbringt.
Matteos Kunden
sind meist Unternehmen,
die gleich
mehrere Hundert Taschen kaufen
und diese an ihre Kunden weitergeben.
Sein finanzieller Vorteil:
eine Gewinnmarge von rund 35 %.
Und noch schöner ist,
dass die Umhängegurte dieser Taschen
aus gebrauchten Auto-Sicherheits-
gurten hergestellt werden.
Das gibt ihnen
zusätzlich einen nachhaltigen Touch.
Etwa 70 % aller Fremdarbeiter in
Dubai arbeiten im Niedriglohnsektor.
Matteo hat lange nach einem
geeigneten Geschäftspartner gesucht.
Wie Mohammad seinen Laden führt,
stimmt für ihn.
Man sollte das hier
nicht negativ bewerten.
Es ist ein Unternehmen,
das seit vielen Jahren produziert,
das einen Nutzen schafft,
Arbeitsplätze
und das sich sicher
an alle staatlichen Regeln hält,
auch an Sicherheits- und Zahlungs-
vorschriften für die Mitarbeiter.
Es ist natürlich anders als das,
was wir aus der Schweiz kennen.
Aber das bedeutet nicht, dass es
falsch oder nicht korrekt ist.
Also muss man die Dinge immer
etwas differenzierter betrachten,
nicht bloss als das,
was man hinter meinem Rücken sieht.
In Katar steigt das Fussballfieber.
Acht neue Stadien
liess das Emirat errichten
und wurde für die Bedingungen
auf den Baustellen stark kritisiert.
Die Gewerkschafterin Rita Schiavi
führt seit 2018
mit einem internationalen Team regel-
mässig Inspektionen vor Ort durch.
Fast 6'000 Menschen haben
an diesem Stadion mitgearbeitet.
500 Subunternehmen
wurden beauftragt.
Die Arbeit war erfolgreich und wir
sind stolz auf diese Leistung.
Wir haben von allen, die mitge-
arbeitet haben, ein Foto angebracht.
Eine Geste zu Ehren der Arbeiter.
Vielleicht ein Ergebnis
guter Gewerkschaftsarbeit.
Am Anfang
hatten wir Schwierigkeiten,
überhaupt mit ihnen
ins Gespräch zu kommen.
Wir fingen ja sehr früh mit der
Kampagne an, schon nach 2010,
als die WM vergeben wurde.
Damals waren die Katari
sehr zurückhaltend,
sogar feindlich, weil alle fanden:
"Nein, das geht gar nicht,
eine WM in Katar."
Sie hatten meiner Meinung nach
auch Angst,
dass sie die WM am Schluss
doch nicht bekommen würden.
Von dem Moment an, als ein
gewisses Vertrauen hergestellt war,
man besprochen hatte,
was man tun wollte,
dass es uns um die Arbeiter ging,
damit es ihnen besser geht,
und wir 2017 den Vertrag mit dem
Supreme Committee unterschrieben -
sozusagen mit der FIFA in Katar,
mit der Bauherrin der Stadien -,
war diese Zusammenarbeit
erstaunlich gut, muss ich sagen.
Sie wurde immer besser in dem Sinn,
dass wir in den Stadien
immer freier wurden,
um auch mit den Leuten zu reden.
Sie bemühten sich sehr und
setzten wirklich immer gleich um,
was wir an Problemen fanden.
Rita besucht das bereits
fertiggestellte Al-Janoub-Stadion:
eine architektonische und -
angesichts der extremen Bedingungen -
auch logistische Höchstleistung.
Das Wüstenklima
war ein wichtiger Punkt,
als das Gewerkschaftsteam
die ersten Inspektionen
auf den Baustellen durchführte.
Ein grosses Problem war die Hitze.
Und das Hitzemanagement
hat sich enorm verbessert.
Er hat uns vorhin erzählt,
dass verschiedene Leibchen
ausprobiert wurden.
Zuerst enthielten sie Eis,
dann wurden die Leibchen schwer.
Dann liessen sie
hochmoderne Leibchen entwickeln.
die kühlen, indem man sie nur hier,
hier und hier mit Wasser füllt.
Dann kühlt das Leibchen
den Körper für mehrere Stunden.
Da probierten sie auch
neue Techniken aus.
Auch das Stadion selbst
wurde mit einem besonderen Kühlsystem
ausgestattet,
um die Spieler
und die unteren Zuschauerränge
vor der Wüstenhitze zu schützen.
Man vermutet auch, dass es
am Anfang relativ viele Leute gab,
die wegen dieses Hitzestresses
Probleme bekamen
oder gesundheitliche Vorerkrankungen
hatten
und dieses Klima und diese Art
von Arbeit dann nicht aushielten.
Und das hat sich enorm verändert.
Sie machen jetzt Screenings,
bevor die Leute kommen,
sodass die Arbeiter überwacht werden
und Leute mit gewissen
gesundheitlichen Probleme
nicht mehr draussen
in der Hitze arbeiten müssen,
sondern
einen anderen Arbeitsplatz bekommen.
Geschätzte 150 Mrd. Fr.
investiert Katar in eine
komplett erneuerte Infrastruktur.
Dazu gehören neben den Stadien auch
Hotels wie das Waldorf Astoria Lusail
von Chris Franzen.
Er steht unter enormem Zeitdruck:
Bis zur WM muss alles fertig sein.
Durch die WM sind die Zustände
auf allen Baustellen
in die Kritik geraten.
Ein grosser Punkt: Viele
Fremdarbeiter müssen hohe Gebühren
an Vermittlungsagenturen bezahlen.
Wir versuchen schon,
das komplett zu eliminieren.
Man muss schon sicher sein, dass man
mit Firmen zusammenarbeitet,
welche die gleiche Philosophie haben
und die gleiche Gesetzgebung
verfolgen.
Sie müssen einfach ethisch
auf der gleichen Ebene sein.
Wir zahlen der Firma eine Fee,
and that's it.
Die dürfen von den Angestellten
nicht auch noch Geld nehmen.
Chris ist Hotelier in dritter
Generation und Druck gewohnt.
Doch die neue Aufgabe hat es in sich:
Sein Hotel soll zur Fussball-WM
ausgewählte VIP-Gäste beherbergen.
Viel Zeit für Experimente
bleibt da nicht.
Great!
Normalerweise,
wenn man ein Hotel eröffnet,
hat man eine gewisse Anlaufzeit von
ein paar Monaten, einem halbem Jahr,
sieben, acht Monaten.
Das ist bei uns nicht der Fall.
Wir öffnen,
und die WM steht vor der Tür.
Bis dann landet fast jedes Problem
auf seinem Tisch -
und sei es auch noch so klein.
Aktuell:
die neuen Mitarbeiter-Shirts.
Mr Koukoulakis.
- Yes, Sir.
Rund 40 km südlich geht die Stadion-
besichtigung in die nächste Runde.
Als Inspektorin achtet Rita nicht nur
auf das Wohl der Bauarbeiter.
Sie erhält auch Einblicke in
die Umziehkabinen der Fussballstars.
Das ist doch etwas,
das man nie zu sehen bekommt.
Da haben alle ihren kleinen Safe,
wo sie ihr Portemonnaie
oder - ich weiss nicht -
Kettchen verstauen können.
Mind. 4,5 Mrd. Fr.
soll Katar insgesamt für den Bau
der neuen Stadien bezahlt haben.
Einige von ihnen werden
nach dem Turnier verkleinert,
umfunktioniert
oder sogar wieder demontiert.
Das war ich auch noch nie:
auf einem Fussballrasen.
In einem richtigen Stadion.
Lange herrschte in Katar
das Kafala-System:
Die Arbeiter
mussten ihre Pässe abgeben
und waren dadurch komplett
von ihren Arbeitgebern abhängig.
Dieses System
ist nun offiziell abgeschafft worden.
In Bezug auf den Stadionbau
war es am Anfang auch so,
dass das Kafala-System
noch existierte.
Sie mussten z.T. noch sehr hohe
Vermittlungsgebühren bezahlen.
Und das ist vielleicht eine
der höchsten Errungenschaften,
dass sie die Gebühr, die sie
schon bezahlt hatten, zurückbekamen.
Vorher mussten sie diese
über Monate abbezahlen.
Mit der Abschaffung
des Kafala-Systems
wurde es für alle Arbeiter besser.
Aber es ist
noch nicht überall implementiert.
Aber hier auf den WM-Baustellen
setzten sie es relativ schnell um.
Darum waren wir nicht
für einen Boykott, sondern sagten:
"Man muss das nutzen,
um die Situation zu verbessern."
Vor zweieinhalb Jahren kam Andrea
Hirschi mit ihrer Familie nach Dubai.
Ihr Coiffeur-Geschäft in Bern führt
die 41-Jährige von hier aus weiter.
Aktuell beträgt der Zeitunterschied
zur Schweiz plus 3 Std.
So kann ich mir am Morgen, nachdem
ich Sophie zur Schule gebracht habe,
hier den Ausgleich holen,
den ich brauche,
damit ich meinen Tag im Büro,
im Office, starten kann.
Die Verwandlung
von der Power- zur Businessfrau
folgt einer festen Routine.
Wenn ich keine Struktur hätte,
wäre das Geschäft nicht da,
wo es jetzt ist.
Ich habe Erfolg gehabt.
Ich führte das Geschäft aus
den schlechten in die guten Zahlen.
Und das in eineinhalb Jahren.
Und das ist schon ...
Darauf kann ich stolz sein.
Einer der Vorteile der Pandemie:
Mittlerweile kann man wirklich von
überall auf der Welt aus arbeiten.
Ich kann von hier aus
auf mein Kassensystem
in der Schweiz zugreifen,
ich sehe, was gemacht wurde.
Ich sehe alle Belege.
Ich mache von hier aus die Löhne.
Ich mache die Buchhaltung.
Ja, dafür zu sorgen, dass es läuft,
dass es auch gut läuft,
ist eine Herausforderung.
Gerade von Dubai aus.
Wann immer es sich einrichten lässt,
schaut Andrea daher vor Ort
nach dem Rechten.
Die seltenen Heimatbesuche nutzt
Andreas Mutter Katharina natürlich,
um ihre Tochter und Enkelin zumindest
kurz zu Gesicht zu bekommen.
Ja,
es ist schon langsam eine Belastung.
Ich denke, so lange
wird sie wohl nicht mehr bleiben.
Hoffen wir es mal.
Ich versuche,
alle drei Monate hierherzukommen.
Dann sehen wir uns kurz,
aber intensiv.
In Andreas Abwesenheit führt Conny
Rotzler, ihre rechte Hand, den Laden.
Ich habe zuerst gedacht:
"Nein, das klappt nie!"
Am Anfang hatten wir Startprobleme.
Es ist lustig,
dass du das sagst:
"Ich glaube, das geht nie.
Das klappt nicht."
Ich hatte immer gedacht,
du seist diejenige, die ...
Ich hatte gezweifelt, nicht du.
Das habe ich dir nie gezeigt.
Ich war ja diejenige, die wegging.
Wir meistern das zusammen sehr gut.
Andrea unterstützt mich halt
zu 200 %.
Wenn es brennt, kann ich direkt
eine Nachricht absetzen -
über WhatsApp oder E-Mail - und sie
kommt immer sofort und versucht,
Lösungen zu finden.
Auch wenn sie weit weg ist,
ist sie immer sehr präsent.
Ja.
Das Geschäft zurückzulassen,
war schwer.
Aber sie
haben es gut auf die Reihe gekriegt.
Am Anfang hatte ich wirklich ...
Ich hatte Panik:
"Schaffe ich das?
Muss ich wieder zurück?"
Ja. Und dann kam dummerweise Corona
und ...
Ach!
Einerseits dumm, andererseits ...
Ich musste mich
einfach reinschicken.
Ich konnte ja nichts mehr machen.
Ich konnte nicht zurückfliegen.
Und das zusammen ... Auch mit Conny.
Ich sage es immer wieder:
Sie ist für mich
ein Sechser im Lotto.
* Anrufsignal *
Guten Morgen.
Regelmässige Videocalls
sind wichtig fürs Tagesgeschäft.
Doch sie führen Andrea
auch vor Augen,
was ihr in der Fremde so sehr fehlt.
Also das ist sehr schwer.
Man merkt auch, ich vermisse es.
Ich vermisse es, im Laden zu stehen,
das Team, die Kunden.
Eben. Hm!
Äh ... So, nochmals.
Also es ist schon ...
... nicht einfach.
Matteo und seine Frau Megan sind
auf dem Weg zum Hotspot The Palm.
Heute hätte ihre grosse
Hochzeitsfeier stattfinden sollen.
Statt mit ihren Familien zu feiern,
gehen die beiden nun brunchen -
im angesagten Bistro
von Megans Freundin Carmen.
Eine tolle Sache, vor der ich
grossen Respekt habe, ist,
dass Carmen
als "Thirty under Thirty"
zu einer der besten Köchinnen
des Nahen Ostens gewählt worden ist.
Und das hat sie verdient.
Sie ist eine fantastische Frau.
Megan und sie
sind wirklich ein enges Team.
Carmen stammt wie Megan aus Südafrika
und ist zudem Megans Trauzeugin.
Thema heute: natürlich
die abgesagte Hochzeitsfeier ...
Carmen und Megan
haben sich in Dubai kennengelernt.
Sie verbindet die
gemeinsame Muttersprache Afrikaans.
* Sie unterhalten sich
auf Afrikaans. *
Am Anfang war das für mich schon
eine seltsame, untypische Sprache.
Mittlerweile verstehe ich mehr,
als sie denken.
Aber ja, Afrikaans ist lustig,
v.a. die Musik.
Ich liebe Afrikaans-Songs.
# Dames ...
So funny.
* Orientalische Musik *
Anders als Dubai startete Katar
erst Mitte der 1990er-Jahre
seinen Modernisierungsprozess.
Für das Emirat ein Balanceakt
zwischen strukturellem Wachstum
und Bewahrung der eigenen Kultur.
Coralie ist als Zweijährige
mit ihrer Mutter aus der Westschweiz
nach Katar gekommen - mittlerweile
ist sie selbst Mutter zweier Kinder.
Nanny Alma sorgt für das Mittagessen.
Ohne ihre Unterstützung
wäre es für Coralie unmöglich,
die Doppelbelastung zu bewältigen.
Danke, Alma.
Sie gehört zur Familie, aber sie
isst lieber für sich allein.
Oft kocht sie dasselbe für sich,
aber sie mag es ruhig und friedlich.
Nach dem Essen gibt es
für den zweijährigen Abdulrahman
nichts Schöneres
als den Disney-Film "Lion King".
Wann immer möglich,
setzt sich sein Vater Saeed dazu.
Ich versuche, so viel Zeit
wie möglich mit ihm zu verbringen.
Aber ich muss arbeiten
und habe meine Motorradkarriere.
Doch ich versuche,
immer Zeit für die Kinder zu finden.
V.a. diese 2 oder 3 Std. nach seinem
Mittagsschlaf, wenn er spielt.
Oh-oh!
- Oh-oh!
Okay.
Multinationale Kindererziehung.
Bei Coralie und Saeed
läuft einiges anders
als in
einer traditionellen Katari-Familie.
Wenn eine Frau ein Kind bekommt,
geht sie für die ersten 40 Tage
normalerweise zurück
ins Haus ihrer Eltern.
Damit ihre Mutter und ihre Schwester
sich in dieser Zeit um sie kümmern.
Aber hier habe ich das gemacht.
Ich habe mich um dich gekümmert.
Ja.
- Also das machen wir anders.
Er ist ein toller Dad, ganz sicher.
Das ist keine Frage.
Seit September 2018 sind Coralie
und Saeed offiziell verheiratet.
Doch da Coralie von den Behörden
immer noch als Europäerin
gesehen wird
und Saeed
bei der Militärpolizei arbeitet,
musste das Paar um seine Ehe kämpfen.
Wenn du jemanden heiraten willst,
der nicht aus Katar stammt,
brauchst du
eine Bewilligung der Regierung.
Ich habe sie beantragt,
sie haben abgelehnt. Dreimal.
Die Bevölkerung von Katar
ist nicht gross.
Es gibt nur neun oder zehn Familien,
die ursprünglich aus Katar stammen.
Meine Familie ist eine von ihnen.
Ich denke, sie wollen ...
... das bewahren.
Ja. Und dass ich jemanden
aus Katar heirate.
Es gibt ein arabisches Sprichwort:
"Hinter jeder Verzögerung
steckt etwas Gutes."
Wir wissen genau:
Wenn wir z.B. streiten, geben wir
deswegen nicht gleich auf.
Wir haben für diese Ehe
so lange gekämpft.
Wir wollen einfach,
dass sie funktioniert.
Unsere Beziehung
ist stärker geworden.
Viel stärker.
- In dieser Zeit der Ungewissheit.
Kennengelernt haben sie sich
an der Rennstrecke.
Die Begeisterung für Motorsport -
auch eine Liebe, die beide teilen.
Die Frau eines Rennfahrers zu sein,
bringt gewisse Vorteile mit sich.
Das habe ich von meinem Mann
zum Geburtstag bekommen.
Patriotisch, wie ich bin ...
Dubai ist die grösste Stadt
der Vereinigten Arabischen Emirate.
Von den rund 3 Mio. Einwohnern
sind rund 85 % Ausländer -
wie Megan und Matteo.
Die beiden
haben sich hier kennengelernt.
Nicht am Strand, sondern per App.
Ich hätte nicht gedacht,
auf Tinder meinen Ehemann
und die Liebe meines Lebens
zu finden,
aber zum Glück
hat es für mich funktioniert.
Am Anfang fanden wir es peinlich,
es jemandem zu sagen,
v.a. in Geschäftskreisen, weil es
irgendwie unromantisch schien.
Später haben wir gemerkt,
dass es in Dubai ganz normal ist.
Aber zuerst haben wir
eine Fake-Story erzählt.
Ja, wir haben uns
eine Geschichte ausgedacht:
Ich hätte meinen Ausweis verloren,
Matteo hätte ihn gefunden
und mich dann auf Facebook
kontaktiert. Aber es war Tinder.
Jetzt planen die beiden ihre
gemeinsame Zukunft - in Dubai.
Aktuell reden sie über
ein grösseres Haus und Nachwuchs.
Familienleben in der Wüstenmetropole.
Wie wird das sein?
In Dubai ist das Leben leichter.
Es besteht schon die Gefahr,
dass du verwöhnt wirst.
Genauso ist es mit deinen Kindern.
Sie wachsen hier ganz anders auf
als in der Schweiz.
Du kannst hier nicht
einfach draussen Fussball spielen.
Auf der anderen Seite lernen sie
hier viele Kulturen kennen,
viele Religionen und Traditionen ...
* Beschwingte Musik *
Eine Lebenskrise
brachte Matteo nach Dubai,
doch der Sprung ins Ungewisse
hat sich als Chance entpuppt.
Sie ist nicht nur meine Frau,
sondern auch mein bester Freund.
Wir haben viel gemeinsam und ...
Ja, es wird nie langweilig,
wirklich nicht.
Anders als Katar
inszeniert sich Dubai
als glitzerndes Touristenparadies.
Fast 17 Mio. Besucher
kamen 2019 ins Land.
Andrea holt einen
besonderen Gast vom Flughafen ab:
Ihr jüngerer Bruder Michael
will gemeinsam mit Andreas Familie
seinen Geburtstag feiern.
Auf meinen Bruder freue ich mich
sehr. Er ist noch nie hier gewesen.
Dabei sind wir jetzt
schon seit zweieinhalb Jahren da.
Und er hat es noch nie geschafft,
nach Dubai zu kommen.
Der Flughafen von Dubai ist
mit rund 80 Mio. Passagieren jährlich
einer der grössten der Welt.
"Moves back to Terminal 1.
Dubai International."
Ach!
Sorry, hi.
I should go to Terminal 1.
Go to this side.
- Okay.
Bern ist schon übersichtlicher.
Stopp.
Aber parkieren kann sie.
Andrea und ihr Bruder
haben ein enges Verhältnis.
Für den Geburtstag hat sie
eine Überraschung vorbereitet.
Er ist ein Hornusser, das ist
eine Schweizer Nationalsportart.
Er ist ziemlich gut,
und ich dachte,
ich gehe mit ihm Golf spielen,
weil das ja ähnlich ist.
Ich glaube,
er wird sich richtig freuen.
Super, jetzt ist er beim Gepäck.
Ich darf mich ja nicht verplappern.
Mein Mund ist
manchmal schneller als mein Hirn.
Sali.
- Hoi. Geht es gut?
Ja, danke. Selber auch?
- Schon lange nicht mehr gesehen.
Michael
ist mit Kollege Jan angereist.
Die Vorfreude auf ein
paar ausgelassene Tage ist gross.
Während Dubai eines der sieben
Vereinigten Arabischen Emirate ist,
geht Katar seinen eigenen Weg.
Die Gigantomanie des Nachbarn
betrachten viele Katari mit Skepsis.
Andererseits entstehen auch in Doha
vielerorts neue, moderne Quartiere -
wie The Pearl,
eine künstliche Insel
mit z.T. exklusiven Luxusimmobilien.
Alles hat sich verändert hier.
Früher gab es
keine Geschwindigkeitsbegrenzung
und man hat noch Kamele
auf der Strasse gesehen.
Das monatliche Durchschnittseinkommen
liegt in Katar bei etwa 4'000 Fr.
Mit ihrem doppelten Einkommen
und Saeeds Preisgeldern
ist Coralies Familie
bisher gut durchgekommen.
Aya, möchtest du später auch
mit Motorrädern zu tun haben?
Willst du einmal
die erste katarische Frau sein,
die internationale Motorradrennen
fährt?
Abdulrahman ist Feuer und Flamme
für alles, was nach Motoren aussieht.
Und Saeed freut's natürlich.
Er ist ein toller Vater. Manchmal
könnte er etwas strenger sein.
Aber er ist viel weg.
Wenn er dann zu Hause ist,
möchte er Abdulrahman
nicht gegen sich aufbringen.
Wenn er Gelegenheit hat,
macht Saeed jeden Spass mit.
In Dubai beschert Andrea
ihrem Bruder Michael
einen Geburtstag der besonderen Art.
# Happy birthday to you,
happy birthday to you.
Die beiden haben schon als Kinder
viel zusammen unternommen.
Da die Eltern berufstätig waren,
lebten Andrea und Michael zeitweise
bei den Grosseltern, in einem Zimmer.
Eine gute,
aber einfache Kindheit ohne Luxus,
die sie bis heute verbindet.
Nein, nicht für dich,
du hattest schon Geburtstag.
Zum Küchlein gibt es als Geschenk
noch eine Sommerfrisur dazu.
Für Andrea eine gute Gelegenheit,
wieder mal zu üben.
Und wie findest du es hier?
Gefällt es dir?
Von der Umgebung,
was du schon gesehen hast?
Ja, bei euch ist es noch schön.
Draussen im Garten
sieht es cool aus.
Aber im Sommer
wäre es mir sicher viel zu heiss.
Die grösste Hitze, die wir letzten
Sommer erlebt haben, war 52 °C.
Das stand in der Autoanzeige.
Da denkst du nur noch:
"Nein, was soll das?"
Für Ferien und so oder eine
begrenzte Zeit ist es sicher cool.
Aber für immer ...
Da finde ich halt die Schweiz schön.
Ein bisschen Tratsch ...
eine Seltenheit für Andrea,
seit sie in Dubai ist.
Das vermisse ich sehr,
dieses Zwischenmenschliche.
V.a., dass die Kunden
den Laden mit einer
grossen Dankbarkeit verlassen -
meistens, auch nicht immer.
Und wo bekommt man sonst
diese Dankbarkeit?
Das ist schon was,
was ich als Hausfrau und Mama ...
Man klopft mir
nicht auf die Schulter und sagt:
"Wow, hast du die Wäsche
aber schön zusammengelegt!"
"Oh, hast du aber
was Gutes zu essen gemacht!"
Du hörst es schon, aber
halt nicht in diesen Intervallen,
wie ich es im Tagesgeschäft habe.
So, wie findest du es?
- Tipptopp.
Baldmöglichst möchte Andrea
eine Freelancer-Coiffeur-Lizenz
für Dubai beantragen.
So.
Auch im schicken Hafenquartier Marina
geht es um die Frisur.
Matteo hat online
einen Coiffeurtermin vereinbart -
für seine beiden Katzen.
Der Coiffeur kommt,
wie hier üblich, direkt nach Hause.
Come. Come, my love.
I got you.
Yeah, I got it.
120 Fr. kostet
die neue Frisur für beide Katzen.
Nicht gerade billig, aber bequem.
Es ist v.a. wichtig im Sommer,
wenn es richtig heiss ist.
Sie sind gerne auf der Terrasse.
Also sorgen wir ab und zu dafür,
dass sie gewaschen werden,
die Ohren gesäubert
und die Krallen geschnitten werden,
einfach als Hygienemassnahme.
Unterdessen muss Chewy, die zweite
Katze, auf ihre Behandlung warten.
Sie ist gerade etwas überfordert,
mit so vielen fremden Menschen.
Ich höre sie auch miauen.
Jetzt fühle ich mich ein bisschen
mies, dass ich sie rausgeholt habe.
Noch abduschen,
dann ist Minny Lou gewappnet,
wenn die Temperaturen
wieder über 40 °C steigen.
So funktioniert hier alles.
Man kann sich Benzin nach Hause
liefern lassen, Lebensmittel, alles,
was man sich vorstellen kann.
Sogar der Coiffeur kommt nach Hause.
Es ist also ziemlich schwierig,
in Dubai nicht faul zu werden.
Die Wüstenstadt ist nach dem
wirtschaftlichen Einbruch 2009
wieder auf Wachstumskurs.
Bei Bauprojekten
wird stets in Superlativen gedacht.
Davon kann sich Michael
selbst überzeugen.
Auch der urbane Event-Golfplatz
protzt mit beeindruckenden Ausmassen.
Wirklich super. Ich freue mich.
in der Schweiz habe ich schon
zweimal einen Abschlag gemacht,
aber noch nie in einer
solchen Location. Das ist megacool.
Ich freue mich richtig.
Der Preis für das Spielvergnügen
variiert zwischen
30 und 60 Fr. pro Stunde.
Hornusser Michael
hat den Dreh schnell raus.
Wer mit weniger Talent gesegnet ist,
kann sich
vom Nebenmann was abschauen.
Oder - noch besser -
von der Nebenfrau.
Hast du gesehen?
Viele Stars und Künstler
zieht es nach Dubai.
Die Dame ist eine DJane.
Sie nimmt sich sogar Zeit
für eine kleine Lektion mit Sophie.
Thank you.
Super!
Man lernt einfach
immer wieder neue Leute kennen.
Es rührt mich.
Die Kleine wird schon wieder
inspiriert für einen neuen Sport.
# Happy birthday to you, happy
birthday, happy birthday to you.
Dubai gilt auch
als Hotspot für Partys.
Ein Weg, den
der eher konservative Nachbar Katar
bei allen Reformen
so wohl nicht beschreiten möchte.
Chris erwartet Gäste, um sich
in privatem Rahmen wieder mal
über die Situation in Katar
auszutauschen.
Eingeladen sind Rita und ihr Mann.
* Türklingel *
Hallo zusammen.
- Hallo, Chris.
Hallo, Rita. Wie geht's? Gut?
- Gut. Danke.
Hattest du eine gute Reise?
- Das ist mein Mann Hans.
Freut mich. Super, seid ihr hier.
Der Hotelsektor ist für Rita ebenso
interessant wie der Stadionbau.
Schliesslich geht es dort auch darum,
langfristig
gute Arbeitsbedingungen zu schaffen.
Knapp 900 Angestellte
beschäftigt Chris in seinem Hotel.
Wird es fertig?
Letzte Woche hatten wir
einen Recruitment-Day in Katar.
Aber du merkst schon:
Es kommen so viele Hotels.
Also der Markt ist trocken -
komplett trocken.
Hier ist das Hotel,
wo wir rekrutiert haben.
Diese Leute warten.
Das ist das Vorscreening.
Die kommen alle und ...
Und wen rekrutierst du jetzt da?
Das war eine Dame
fürs Frontoffice, sehr wichtig.
Das Gesicht des Hotels sozusagen.
- Hast du jemanden gefunden?
Ja, wir haben
schon ein paar Leute gefunden.
Für mich ist wichtig, dass jemand
die richtige Einstellung hat.
Alles andere kann ich trainieren.
Wenn sie schon trainiert sind
und verstehen,
worum es Hotelgewerbe geht,
ist es noch besser.
Housekeeping.
Sona aus Aserbaidschan.
Sie war
vorher in einem anderen Hotel.
Das sind Leute,
die schon woanders arbeiten?
Das sind Leute, die hier in Katar
sind und für andere Hotels arbeiten.
Und die können jetzt wechseln.
Ja. Früher wäre das
gar nicht möglich gewesen.
Wegen des Wandels
im Arbeitsgesetz geht das.
Ja, das wäre früher
nicht möglich gewesen.
Das Kafala-System erlaubte das nicht
und jetzt ist das gefallen.
Und darauf
bin ich schon ein bisschen stolz.
Das ist ein Erfolg unserer Arbeit,
dass der Staat Katar das
Kafala-System jetzt abgebaut hat.
Es ist natürlich klar - und es war
uns immer klar und ein Anliegen:
Dadurch können die Leute
bessere Arbeitsplätze suchen
und verdienen mehr.
Das ist natürlich eine ganz
wichtige gewerkschaftliche Forderung
und Errungenschaft.
Ja, absolut.
Merci, Rita, merci, keine Frage.
Chris als gelernter Koch
gibt sein Bestes.
Es läuft alles, siehst du?
- Ich koche übrigens auch gerne.
Das ist der beste Zeitvertreib.
- Ja.
Eine schöne Champignonrahmsauce,
wie wir es gelernt haben.
Wenn ich koche,
darf er nicht in die Küche.
Er sagt einem immer,
wie man es besser machen soll.
Also darf er nicht in die Küche.
Das internationale Gewerkschaftsteam
hat heute mit der katarischen
Regierung darüber verhandelt,
wie man die Verbesserungen
auf den WM-Baustellen dauerhaft
und v.a. für alle Arbeiterinnen und
Arbeiter in Katar durchsetzen kann.
Wir haben gerade heute
das Abkommen unterschrieben
mit dem Arbeitsministerium, weil
das Abschaffen des Kafala-Systems
auch
noch nicht überall funktioniert.
Die ganzen Verbesserungen sind
noch nicht überall implementiert.
Und das ist jetzt auch
unsere grosse Sorge.
Wir wollen nicht sagen: "Jetzt ist
die WM vorbei, wir gehen wieder."
Aber ich habe ja mit diesen Leuten
aus den Ministerien täglich zu tun.
Und ich kann wirklich sagen:
Da ist ein Drive, ein Wille,
die wissen, es geht nur so vorwärts.
Und es würde mich
schwer enttäuschen,
wenn sie das nach der WM
wieder zurücknehmen würden.
Damit hätte ich ein Problem,
das muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen.
Chris und Rita -
zwei, die den Strukturwandel in Katar
in dieser spannenden Zeit
mitgestalten.
In der nächsten Folge:
Sonntagsausflug in die Wüste.
Andrea muss ihren Jeep
sicher durch die Dünen steuern.
Ausserdem: hoher Besuch
in der Schweizer Botschaft.
Hotelier Chris trifft
die Schweizer Fussballprominenz.
Und: Solidarität
für die Migrationsarbeiter.
Der Einsatz von Gewerkschafterin Rita
trägt Früchte.
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
puretype gmbh - 2022